[Music]
it's a Kardashian Christmas Extravaganza
on Sundays new episode of keeping up
it's so exciting Kris Jenner plans to do
her holiday shopping and differently
this year
nobody's ever gonna recognize me what
are you guys doing for some trucks for
my grandchildren by going incognito in
recent years it's become a little more
challenging to go shopping to say the
least because we start to get recognized
and then I get distracted and I can't
get my shopping done so leave it to
Jonathan he thinks it would be a really
good idea for us to go in the disguise
and Kim gets a little territorial about
her decorating tactics see this is the
kind of Christmas tree I want I want
like a real bark tree but I won't tell
all my ideas out loud my mom is
somewhere lurking I have warned everyone
that I will come for them if they even
dare try to copy anything that I'm doing
this holidays
despite the Christmas chaos we know it's
all in good fun families everything so
that comes first
you know so they've always really
prioritized they really have their their
priorities together and I'm proud of
that
[Music]
you
[Music]